So I approach adding new features in
a way that I try to be very
specific about what I'm adding.
Because, of course,
you could have a redesign of an
application that has a number of things.
But, I think it's important to
focus on one item at a time.
So if you're adding an image to a view
or you're adding several buttons or
a layout, it's good to accomplish those
individual pieces first and then,
kind of, just get something that
works and then evolve that over time.
The general thing I'm trying to avoid
is you can get into a rabbit hole of
everything needs to be refactored.
And you refactor one thing and
you start to pull other threads because
you start to change something else, and
then at the of the day you
don't have anything done.
So it's important to stay very focused
on improving one area of the code base
and then just finishing that.
Even if there's things that you kind of
use as scaffolding, like you know it's
going to tear down later as you improve
other features, that's okay, it's okay
to tear that out later, but it's
good to just focus on that one item.
When I plan out
implementing new features,
it depends on how large that feature is.
If it's a large feature then
I'll generally do some amount of
project planning.
Like you'll say, okay, well this might
take me weeks so I'll schedule it into
sprints, and start to get an idea of
what I'll tackle for those weeks.
If it's a smaller item,
I kind of do that in my head.
I'll say, I know,
I need to do this one activity first and
then transition to the other one and
kind of build those over time.